Film Courage: Why do distributors
no longer do marketing?
Jeff Deverett, Film Producer, Entrepreneur,
Writer, Director: Because they don't care
about the movies, there's no passion
for the movies, it's just about
numbers. They look at a movie they say
Can we make money off of it? If they can,
then they're not emotionally attached. When
a filmmaker makes a movie, I don't want to
be this is a crazy analogy, but it's like having a
child. It's a big deal, making a movie is a major,
major deal in someone's life the amount of time,
effort, money that you put into it this sweat that
you put into it's a big, big deal and you are so
emotionally attached to it and it's such a major
part of who you are in your life because it's such
a gigantic commitment and a huge accomplishment
distributors don't share any of that they don't
have any of that passion they don't understand
any of that pain as a matter of fact I have lots
of distributor friends obviously I come from that
world and we're constantly talking at dinner I
say you guys you don't even understand it's what's
there to understand Jeff you don't understand how
emotionally attached people are and how important
it is and when you just fluff it off and how
hurtful it is well it's business Jeff and I
say I know it's business I know it's business
but I've been on both sides of this business
and I understand what filmmakers go through and
what they are dealing with so I'm not asking you
to be bad business people or anything like that
but they're not emotionally involved and they're
not even financially involved these days anymore
so they have no stake in it like when I say
financially involved getting a minimum guarantee
at least gets them connected and gives them a
little bit of risk but it's hard to get that
now it's especially a significant one that where
makes them sweat a little bit see very rare you
get that so when there's no financial attachment
or no emotional attachment why should they have
to get behind it and put too much effort into it
basically it's a volume game for them now because
a lot of their business is on AVOD platforms
where it's basically throw it all up there and
see whatever watch people watch and just take
a piece of it and if if you have a hundred of
them going at the same time then hopefully the
volume will be enough that you can make some real
money but individually each person's not going
to make very much but they don't care because
their business is volume and their business is
I hate to say this because it's going to disturb
a lot of filmmakers who are watching this but
I'm going to wager to guess that most distributors
don't even watch the movies that they distribute
they might watch 10 minutes of it maybe they
flip through and watch the first 10 the middle
10 the last 10 just to make sure it's in focus and
working can you imagine that somebody selling your
movie who hasn't even watched it how disappointing
that would be and they're supposed to talk about
it and be passionate about it they've never seen
it so that's why they don't do marketing because
they don't really care and that's why a filmmaker
has to do it because they do care and they're
going to do it with more passion now maybe not as
much skill because they don't do that for a living
and that's why it would be helpful to deal with
people who do do it for a living and yeah will
any marketer feel as passionate about the film as
the filmmaker no of course not nobody's going to
feel more passionate about their children than the
parents right but there are people who will feel
more passionate than the like teachers would feel
more passionate about kids than than or coaches
or something like that people are connected the
way a filmmaker like but a distributor they just
don't care that's the main reason how they say a
good artist should have a manager and an agent but
also be looking to book their own work don't rely
just you'll be waiting by the phone or your email
so is it similar that if you get a distribution
deal if you're lucky enough to have gotten that
that then you are finding who your audience
is you're going out there and you're
actually dealing with them you're not relying
on well my distributor just won't they don't
care it's just business to them once in a while
you'll get lucky and a distributor will get behind
it and really try hard and because they realize
that there's potential and if they put a lot of
resources behind it they'll generate more revenue
and be more successful with it once in a while
but I would not take that for granted so as
you say don't rely on it if it happens feel
like you're lucky in it and you
won the lottery don't rely on it
figure that even when you get distribution
you're going to have to support the
distribution efforts with your marketing
and awareness creation as much as you can
and maybe you can't maybe you can't and that's
why a lot of filmmakers get disappointed with
distribution deals because they say hey I gave
it to a distributor and they did nothing with
it they stuck it on a couple of platforms I could
have done that myself they basically did nothing
they and they didn't so I say to them what did
you do well it's not my job to do it it's the
distributors I said well that's the new norm the
new narrative that I'm talking about it actually
is your job now and I've heard that from a lot
of actors filmmakers writers that's why I have
a manager but then they don't want to do other
things that could actually help propel them
in the new narrative that I'm talking about the
the manager agent thing and if you want to talk
on the talent side is basically the manager
needs to navigate the business elements so
that the person doesn't have to deal learn to
become their own lawyer and business person
the agent just needs to keep an eye on what the
opportunities are right but in the distribution
world what is a producer writer director who's
making an indie film what's the manager going
to do they're going to negotiate a distribution
contract for them there's so many people who can
do that and I'm not sure they're going to do
it well anyways and agents like first of all
I think that most indie film people aren't
going to get that anyways for two reasons one
is they can't afford it like an agent manager
they want to make money they want retainers
yeah sure they're going to take a percentage
but they at least want a retainer so who can
actually afford to have those people on staff
and working for you and secondly agent managers
need to also make a living so hence they want
to deal with potentially bigger stuff and indie
films generally aren't big enough the odd one
is that will make enough money to pay a five
percent commission to an agent or whatever it is
but for the most part they aren't that's why it's
so hard for indie filmmakers especially writers
to get representation because the agents don't
want to spend too much time on it because they
don't feel there'll be a return on their time
can you make a commercially viable movie for
$250,000 so it's interesting that number gets
thrown around a lot these days a quarter of a
million I used to throw around the number 750 like
that was the number that you needed to spend to
make a decent movie and I always used to say hey
I'm a decent filmmaker but remember I didn't go
to film school I went to law school and business
school so I have the business side down pat
I didn't go to film school so maybe I don't
have the artistic side down pat as much but
but when it comes to spending money I kind of
know how that all works and I used to say as a
filmmaker I think you got to spend at least 750
to make a decent movie just because you got to
give yourself enough time to do it properly and
assuming you want to pay people I don't ever I
don't have the connections to have people work
for free and I don't really want to ask them to
work for free so I'm not overpaying or I'm not
paying nobody's going to get rich but I'm paying
a fair salary that type of thing so just based on
my experience I always felt 750 sort of was the
minimum and somewhere between 750 and a million
and a half was a decent amount to get a decent
movie like good quality good production value
costumes wardrobe and make the resources
you need to deliver a good movie but
a lot of stuff has changed in technology right so
obviously cameras are cheaper and you don't need
as much gear sometimes as much staff crew
sometimes you get locations are available
talent has not gone down in price if anything
has gone up so a lot of filmmakers say to me
yeah I can make a really good movie for for 250
and I say okay I'm not going to argue with that
but don't think just because you put your
heart and soul into it and you tried your best
that it makes it into a good movie the ultimate
test is let's watch the movie and see if it's good
don't say hey I only had 250 to spend and that's
the best you can do for 250. that's not gonna fly
in the real world nobody's gonna care they're
gonna say okay nice try but we don't want to
spend our time and money watching your movie it's
not like oh wow let's watch the best movie that
was made for 250. it doesn't work that way so if
you can really look it lots of people have done it
lots of people have made movies for less than
100 grand we know that there's these stories
and myths and legends out there of all these
great films that were made for very low budgets
I just don't I think those are anomalies I
think they happen far and few between but
if you're a great filmmaker and you got a good
crew and the chemistry's right and the story's
right and the acting and everything happens then
what the heck I don't as I say to all my clients
the customers out there i.e the viewers nobody's
going to ask you how much you spent on your movie
all they're going to ask you they're just going
to look at your movie and say is it good or bad
they don't care how much you spend and by the
way when people talk about how much they spend
they lie anyways everybody always says they spend
10 times more than they did and some of it's real
because remember they're not getting paid so
people say oh I made a film for fifty thousand
dollars and then I say great how many hours did
you put oh I put 2 000 hours of my time in did
you include that no how much would you make an
hour hundred dollars so that's twenty thousand
dollars of time that you didn't include in
your in your scenario so your film wasn't
fifty thousand was seventy thousand because
if somebody was going to make the same film
they'd have to make it for seventy thousand if I
did my math rate it wasn't I didn't mean $200,000
I meant $20,000 time of their time so people
don't factor that in so the numbers are always
skewed anyways about how much somebody spent on a
movie but at the end of the day it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how much somebody spent the
only thing that matters is that the movie's good
so I applaud anybody who can make a great movie
for a little amount of money and by the way the
people who say to me I can make a movie for 250 I
say maybe you should be making some of my movies
because I'd be making a lot more money if we were
delivering my movies for 250 if you could deliver
them oh well you should give me a chance Jeff
and I said I I don't trust that it can happen
and maybe I'm skewed maybe I think you need
these resources and everything like that so
I do believe that there are people out there who
making really good stuff for 250 and maybe cheaper
but don't think because you spent 250 that the
contest is not who made the best movie for 250.
the contest is did you make a great movie and
it doesn't matter what you made it for because
if you didn't make a great movie I don't care if
you spent two two and a half million if you didn't
make a great movie you're not in the game your
movie's not selling the movie's got to be good
and I know we didn't talk about that before when
I talk about distribution but remember I said I'm
going to check that box that you made a great
movie you got to make a good movie fair is fair
right if you want somebody to pay and spend their
time watching your movie and pay to watch it give
them some value give them some entertainment value
give them a good movie does having a higher budget
let's say over 500 000 guarantee that your movie
is probably going to be of a higher caliber story
wise if you're a good producer slash director like
a good producer director team who knows how to
deploy their resources very very effectively then
I would say the more you have to spend the better
quality your movie is likely going to be as long
as you're not wasting it like if you're putting it
on screen like if you let's say I'll give you
an example okay let's say you have a $500,000
movie right and then you get an extra $50,000
if you go and hire like a fancy caterer who's
going to do the meals yeah will your crew and cast
feel a little bit better sure they will but will
it make your movie better probably not but if you
spend that fifty thousand dollars potentially on
one scene where it's a big production a bigger
location with more extras or something like that
then it'll make your movie better so that's
what by deploying the resources effectively
so if you're you always have to be careful with
your resources no matter what you have so people
think at 250 I have to be more careful than at 500
no you have to be careful of both levels and at
750 just deploy them as best you can so that you
put most of it on screen so that your movie looks
better so obviously the more you have to spend
if you're deploying it wisely you have a better
chance at making a higher quality looking movie
potentially more production value now obviously
it's going to always end up there's there's
elements that doesn't matter how much you spend
acting all right now you could say the more I
spend on actors the better actors I'm going to
get I don't personally believe that I believe
that there's good actors at every price range
and hopefully get good performances out
of them all right so you could say I'll
get a better cinematographer if I spend more
money you'll definitely get a more experienced
cinematographer because they have that's why
they're charging more because they've done more
and chances are it's more predictable but it
doesn't mean a brand new cinematographer can't
shoot a great movie there's young upcoming people
who are really talented who just need a break so
hopefully you get one of those and directors and
all this kind of stuff hopefully it all gels and
so I that's where you the magic can happen
at low budgets where everything gels and
you just get great performances great
directing sometimes experience does
matter and you don't make the rookie errors
because you've done it before and that's why
spending more money on people who know what
they're doing is a little bit more predictable
but it doesn't mean that people who
haven't done it before can't do it well
but to get back to your question yeah if you had
an extra 250 and you put most of it on screen
your movie's going to look better it's just going
to look bigger and hopefully like when I say on
screen you're using more extras your costumes are
better your production value is better by the way
if if the story is bad the acting's bad you could
spend 5 million and still come up with a bad movie
a bad movie is going to be a bad movie so it does
start with a decent story a decent vision from
the director and good performances and then the
rest is just capturing it properly focus sounds
the shots you choose that kind of stuff earlier
you said the audience doesn't care what you paid
for your movie I know film festival audiences
might care though because they just want to know
what was your budget range and how can I emulate
what you did kind of everybody lies I go to tons
of festivals I sit in these screenings and they
say well how much was your budget oh I'm going
to tell you the truth and then they they usually
triple it or quadruple it nobody wants to say they
made a 10 000 movie because it feels too small
right so how do what's real unless you've done the
accounting for it I've been there done that I know
what things cost I know now when a filmmaker says
to me hey I didn't pay anybody then I say great
you're lucky that you got people to work for free
I don't do the movies that way I believe they
should get paid but I'm not saying it's wrong
sometimes people say oh I spent five years making
my movie because I just shot on weekends or this
or that type of thing I say okay fine but I'll
gain it's not my business model I'd rather shoot
20 days consecutively get it done release it
do the next thing so everybody's got a sort of
a different business model and a different vision
of what that could be but when I say people don't
care about how much they spent people like to
discuss it they like to throw numbers around they
like to because they want a point of reference for
themselves to see can I make a movie how much does
it really cost so there are people who are curious
especially at festivals who want to sort of know
because maybe they're thinking of making their
own movies so they're doing that as a point of
reference but if you've watched a movie and you've
left the theater and you said wow that's a great
movie and then somebody said to you oh that cost
fifty thousand or five million you'd be way more
impressed if it was fifty thousand wouldn't it
be way more because all of a sudden this great
movie this epic movie was made for fifty thousand
dollars the surprise would be on the low end as
opposed to the high end so I always joke and I say
if I would ever win an academy award in my speech
I'm gonna say what the actual budget was because
it's gonna be so much lower than what anybody
expected it to be because everybody expects if
it's a good movie that it has to cost all so much
money and by the way here's the other problem with
the narrative that that indie filmmaker everybody
throws around Hollywood style numbers oh I'm
making like I told you before I get phone calls
I'm making a five million dollar feature and it's
all ready but I just need finance and distribution
I say whoa time out you're you're making a five
million dollar feature but it's not finance and
you don't have distribution so how are you making
the five million dollar feature again like in your
mind you're making a five million dollar feature
but in reality what you're probably going to spend
is fifty thousand dollars that's what's really
going to happen if you want this feature made
unless you are connected to some really high
net worth individuals who are prepared to make
big donations to you so everybody still throws
around the big numbers especially in the Hollywood
circles and everybody wants to pretend holly and
at festivals it's Hollywood talk right which is
2.5 I made my movie for 3.2 and blah blah blah and
it's like all right whatever doesn't look like you
did so it's different strokes for different folks
what does it cost to get bankable stars in your
movie so bankable stars you mean a-list talent
basically people who can who people say who's in
it and when you say the name they say oh I know
that person that's a bankable star all right so
that's what I call bankable because there are sort
of secondary bankable words oh I've heard of that
person as opposed to oh when someone goes to see
a movie in the theater the first question they ask
is who's in it and that's why a-list actors make
so much money because people say oh if they're
in it I'll go see the movie right they don't say
what's the movie about they generally say who's
in it even for animated films they'd say that's
the crazy part like you're talking voice a talent
so what does it cost it's flexible
but a-list talent cost more than
it than indie film producers can afford and the
other thing is that chances are a-list talent
doesn't want to do indie films unless it's their
story or they're personally connected and they
want to direct and the reason is is because an
a-list actor does not want to be associated with
a c-list film like the production value is too
low and it's going to taint their reputation
I say unless it's their story and they're or
they're very connected to the filmmaker or
whatever and they want to help share that vision
so I'm going to say that a-list talent is in the
seven-figure range like the million-dollar
plus range b b or say a minus list or b
plus is going to be high six figures and when
you're making a movie for a half a million dollars
or even a million dollars and you want an a-list
actor then your budget just doubled you're gonna
have a two million dollar movie now a lot of
people will say all the distributors are watching
this will say it's worth it because that's
what's going to sell the movie and they're right
it is worth it if for sure you got a sale on the
movie see if you go that route and you don't get
your sale you've just doubled your budget you've
taken a huge risk and maybe it's not going to
work but some people say it's a better risk
to put an a-list actor in and spend that money
it's less of a risk than it is to not have that a
lot of international distributors will say to you
don't even bother making a movie unless you have
recognizable bankable talent which I don't totally
disagree with but the genre I work in family I
don't really use any recognizable talent because
I think it's more about the story than it is about
the actor no it recognizable talent wouldn't hurt
but I don't think the numbers would justify in
terms of the selling side the cost of the actor
now there's some people that use previous a-list
actors who maybe now have become I don't know what
their rating would be but then there's a draw
in that too that someone that had been out of
the limelight for a while hadn't been working
for whatever the reason is and now has made a
comeback and they may be totally different persona
wise appearance wise than they once were and then
that's probably a draw as well very very big
draw that's very very common I call them a minus
or b plus list actors people who are not in the
limelight they're not the top 50 or whatever in
Hollywood but they're still they've done they've
been there done that and are very recognizable
very good for international sales because
people still recognize their face or their name
so that's much more common and it is bankable
also but it's not cheap a b-list actor could be
50 000 a day not uncommon to see that at all
and they're worth it first of all they're good
actors right so you pretty well can depend on
them giving a good performance usually and yeah
they have that that sale ability or what you call
the bank ability and you don't know for sure how
bankable it is but you're pretty certain it's
better to have them not than not to have them
but it's just it's just a finance equation right
so like if you were to say to me why don't you put
like two b list actors in to lead roles in your
movie and I'm gonna say because it'll double the
be half a million dollars in in that fee and
I don't think I'm gonna I think I'll only
increase my sales by say $350,000. I'm doing
some calculations beforehand and saying
it's not feasible for me to do that but if I
did it the other way and said by putting a 500
000 actor in I could get a million dollars
of extra sales of course I would do it
what's the likelihood of someone who just
has an idea so no screenplay no trailer no
artwork no attachments getting a pitch
inside Netflix minus one to zero unless
unless they have an agent who is really likes them
a lot and wants to get them in there first of all
Netflix doesn't take unsolicited pitches none of
the streamers take insulin none of the studios or
the streaming companies take unsolicited
pitches meaning you can't phone them up
they don't have like a place a website or
an entry point where you can phone them up
and say I have a great idea I'd like to pitch
you it doesn't exist they publish that that's
right on their website okay so the only way you
can get in is with either a agent slash manager
a lawyer so whoever somebody who's connected
internally in there or a distributor who's done
business with them all right that's the only
way that you can even attempt to get a pitch
so so right away you can't get indirectly so maybe
you can get in that way but highly highly highly
unlikely also because you haven't done anything
before they have a lineup and let's talk Netflix
netflix has a lineup at their store so long they
have every single major filmmaker in the world
who has done anything wants to do it for Netflix
right because they got a gigantic audience right
so think of all the people ahead of you in line
and what their credentials are relative to what
your credentials are so I would say if you want
to attempt it then you try to get in line for an
agent who you're not going to get the time of day
from either so then keep working at your craft
sounds like don't don't don't just expect to
jump along here's the way to yeah you're not
going to jump the line there's no way and I can't
even think of getting lucky to jump the line
the the only way that you can sort of get ahead
a little bit is is do something make something
that is notable that gets you that that that
their usher says hey who did that and takes you
closer to the to use a metaphor type of thing
right and that would be here's a crazy crazy
counter-intuitive thing about Netflix that
most people don't know which makes no sense
but it's true and it's not just Netflix by
the way it's pretty well all the streaming
companies okay it's pretty well all the big
releasing companies the more popular you have
the more success you've done in when you've
released your movie the more attractive you
are to Netflix so get this you want to make a
move you want it you want to get their attention
make a movie put it onto youtube for free
create as much awareness as possible spend
effort tons of effort creating
awareness get two million views
then all of a sudden you're going to get
onto their radar screen and everybody says
wait wait a second I just gave my movie away to
two million people like why would anybody want
it now after that and I'd say they would
say because they have 160 million people
and 2 million is a test market for them and they
just need to see that hey people 2 million people
like your movie then all of a sudden now they're
going to be interested that's the best way to get
their attention now how do you get that getting
you go viral you have a great movie you create
awareness that's what this is all about but that's
how you get the attention of a major streamer
now it's as counterintuitive as that sounds it's
not really when you think about the theatrical
business right the movies that Netflix wants
the most and all the major streaming companies
are the big movies and pre-covet the big movies
open theatrically to half a billion dollars worth
of business like 500 000 or 50 million people
seeing these I don't know whatever the numbers are
didn't do the math properly but 25 million people
have already seen the movie why would anybody want
that everybody's already seen it but yet those
are the ones that are most coveted and have the
get the biggest payoffs at the streaming companies
why because the streaming companies believe that
people want to see them again these are big
movies and they'll want to be seen twice
and then or three or four times and that's
why they're so valuable even though they've
already been seen you don't use it's like love
you don't use it up there's endless amounts so
you don't yeah you use up one view with a viewer
but they have ten more left or five more whatever
the case may be so that's why I'm saying if
you can release a movie an independent movie
and get tons and tons of awareness then
you'll you'll get on the radar screen a
lot better you'll get to the front of the line a
lot quicker and people will say okay I like this
what else you got so on one hand plan for success
submit to some of these higher tier festivals
don't don't just assume don't rest on that
you'll get in but at the same time don't sabotage
yourself where you think that you just have this
amazing idea and somehow you can get in to Netflix
to pitch it with no other vetting yeah I don't
believe in miracles but if you believe in miracles
like that would be in the miracle category like I
have a great idea I've never done anything before
and I think that I'm gonna get in the door on
Netflix and they're gonna fall in love with it
so to me that that's a miracle that's like so
far beyond reality maybe it's happened I doubt it
maybe it could happen once and maybe everybody the
myths and legends will be created around it but
I put that in the category of a miracle how about
we move the needle a little bit of miracles and
talk about a finished screenplay first finished
screenplay am I getting into Netflix you're still
in the you're still in the category of miracles
you're just maybe a little further down okay yeah
no you're if you're not a proven writer first
of all they're not reading it second they're not
accepting it they're not reading it unless it goes
in through a literary agent who they do business
with which you can potentially do that but how do
you get that literary agent you got to get them
so that's almost as hard as getting into Netflix
itself so you're still it's tough I know it's not
like this is one of those things where
you say speak the truth and the truth
kind of hurts a little bit yeah it's reality
so you've got this screenplay you put your
heart and soul into it it's probably really
good and you can't get anybody to read it
so that's why sometimes you go down both paths you
spend a lot of time getting an agent or trying to
get an agent who hopefully can get in the door
and pitch it to somebody but you don't put all
your eggs in that basket at the same time you
start to think about okay how do I do this myself
maybe one happens before the other or you never
know and we go back to the einstein quote yeah so
so you're not you're not banging your head
against a wall and you're trying a different route
which is more of a proven route instead of my
thing is different because we all think our
story is special yeah and there's nothing against
anybody's story or their writing or their skill
but you kind of have to go through certain
channels it can't just be yeah like Hollywood
and when I say Hollywood I'm including like not
just the studios I'm including the big streamers
now and the basically the people who control most
of the eyeballs they've done a really good job of
locking out all the indies that's they don't do
it on purpose but the reason they do it is because
they they deal in such high caliber product it's
a business decision right like they're dealing in
very very high-end production quality content and
actors and that type of thing and they just don't
need to waste any time on indie film production
it's just it's a nuisance it's aggravating
like that's it any game they have so many so much
time in a day why would they spend it on that
when they have the resources to do so much more
bigger caliber stuff which is what they're doing
like look at this what the streamers offer now the
value that they give to to consumers ten dollars a
month for like multi-million dollar productions
with a-list actors and fantastic storylines and
writing and everything like that how do you beat
that like you're an indie film producer like how
do you even compete with that so looking at it
from that perspective like fear is fair right they
got a business to run they got viewers to satisfy
so and they have all the resources to do it and
revenue coming in from subscribers so why do they
need to focus on why does any exec at a streaming
company need to read an indie script when they got
50 other scripts sitting beside them written by
in-house writers who were high-caliber successful
people who are on staff they don't that's that's
the reality because here's the thing about indie
filmmaking that I'm going to give it credit for
it's generally a lot more creative than than
all than big budget film that the big bunch
of stuff is very well done and I love it but it's
predictable it's formulaic it's a lot of sequels a
lot of stuff like that because they they know what
the audience wants they just keep giving them the
same thing over and over so the innovative stuff
is going to come from the indie film world and the
big studios know that it's just very aggravating
to access it all so once in a while there's a
breakthrough and they have lots of innovation
internally as well they encourage innovation from
their internal writers but the cutting edge stuff
is coming from the indie film world so that's
where the indie film world has a little bit of not
an advantage but you know it's a unique approach
but it's just a matter of organizing it to get
it through so that it can get through the system
can we go back in time to that first Netflix
meeting you had what year was this 2014 14 or
15. yeah 14 or 15. the first one was 14 because
I hadn't made the movie yet I made the movie in
15 the first one so I pitched them before I made
the movie how did you get that meeting Netflix
was a different company back then they actually
what I actually phoned them up and I emailed I
got the name you could get they published email
addresses like the company wasn't gigantic it
was big obviously it was still very big but it
wasn't what it is today and you could actually get
the names of buyers and you could email
them and they would actually return an email
so that's what I did I emailed oh I had to email
probably 15 or 20 times made cut left a couple of
voice messages because you could also get that
and then finally I got a return phone call and
I had done other movies before so it wasn't my
first had it been my first I probably wouldn't
have gotten them the meeting that that was my
fourth movie the one that I pitched them on
so I'd already made three before so I
kind of knew what I was doing I said I
here's what I've made here I'm an experienced
filmmaker blah blah blah I've got this movie
you got the Olympus coming up can I pitch you
on it so they heard the pitch but then they
said we can't take a chance on you until we see
the movie so make the movie and then come back
but they didn't guarantee anything they just said
make the movie and show it to us when it's done
so the movie finished yeah how soon before you're
picking up the phone or emailing after that
the movie wrapped at 505 on a thursday and at 506
I was picking up the phone literally okay no no I
was I was just saying okay I'm finished shooting I
didn't show it to them obviously until after it's
finished edited and everything like that but no no
I was anxious but again back then I was depending
on it a little bit more and I was much more
hopeful than I am today in terms of my realism
level so because I was a little more naive the
truth the truth is I just wasn't as beaten up as
I am now so I really really was hoping that they
would take it but by the way the movie before that
I made it for Disney and I had I had got into
Disney and I it was called king of the camp
it was a kids movie a camp musical just like camp
rock and it was really it was great movie I loved
making it and it was so Disney and I met with the
Disney channel twice and we talked about it and
I came really really close so I knew I had the
flavor I had the taste of what it was to be and
ultimately they said no and it broke my heart but
at least I got there at least I had the pitch and
I sat in the Disney office and and they watched
the trailer and I saw I got to that and they saw
the movie and ultimately and it was it was a
fair note I think it was terrible no to get
but as they say no is the second best answer but
so so I'd been there done that so with Netflix
it was like okay I'm not going to set myself up
for disappointment but I really really really
want this and I got lucky and it sounds like too
there were ways to get in touch with people that
you said you were incredibly naive but also there
were there was more access points way more access
so there's no more access like back then it wasn't
like they would not look at unsolicited material
they actually looked at unsolicited material now
it's done it's finished they get it's they're
too big they have too many yeah it's so that
what happened back then does not happen anymore
for obvious reasons yeah it's so tiny and
by the way they weren't doing any original
programming back then they just probably started
I forget what their first series was that they
made internally but it was all all acquisitions so
they needed product so there was a lot look at the
year that I sold them that movie I can't remember
statistically they told me I can't remember the
number exactly but they it was something like
they bought 900 independent films that year
and the year I sold them the last movie they
bought 300. oh wow so because they're making
stuff internally right so they don't need as
much external product as they do now they still
need some but generally it's bigger stuff so it's
gotten harder and by the way it's funny so I've
got three movies on Netflix and I sold them three
I think I have less of a chance now even having
done business with them three times of actually
selling them something more than I had back then
just because they're so big and they have
so much internal production that it's gotten
even more difficult since you'd already worked in
distribution didn't you have a number of contacts
you could count on to try to get you in the door
even after let's say some of the window closed of
their email addresses being online for you
to access them yeah absolutely no a lot of
distribution is networking and people who worked
at one company often end up in another company or
switch around and you keep hopefully you have
your friendships with them and your business
relationships and they I do get a lot of pitch
meetings that way because I know people that's
a big component of distribution as it is in any
business right is networking so yeah so I'm not
as active in distribution anymore so I don't have
as many contacts as all newer people and younger
people but the people who I have known for many
years who are still active I still get meetings
how does one become active in distribution let's
suppose someone's starting from the ground level
and they want to be able to build that rapport
with people what are some good ways they can do
it themselves so it's funny you ask that because
I do teach at san diego state university I teach
filmmaking and I said to a lot of my students that
you might want to consider going into distribution
to start your career not production and know that
in five or ten years after you do distribution
you'll end up hopefully in production and just
make sure you guide yourself in that direction
that's how you do it you got to work in it like
you can't expect to be a working film producer and
understand the distribution circles because you're
not in them you got to work in a distribution
company go to the markets meet your competitors
meet other people meet buyers the distribution
companies are constantly meeting with buyers their
drink having drinks and dinner and all this kind
of stuff and meetings and you get to know these
people and you develop relationships over time
but you have to work in distribution to develop
those relationships or go to film markets so buy
a pass no no no no you can go to film markets and
kind of be on the periphery but you're not going
to get in the inner circles I see yeah no if you
really want to get those relationships you got it
like listen a lot of people go to film markets and
festivals and sit in panels and see the people and
once in a while somebody's nice enough to answer
some questions or meet afterwards or whatever
but it's not the same you're not developing that
kind of relationship because you're not doing
business together you're just kind of an irritant
that you're a filmmaker who wants their attention
that's that's the truth so they'll if
they're polite they'll give you the time
of day most of them are polite so they don't
bother because they don't it's like being
a celebrity everybody wants your attention and
you just don't have time to give it to everybody
and everybody's going to pitch on the same
thing and just get tired of it after a while
like if you're a Netflix buyer at a market you're
a celebrity like you almost need security to walk
through the marketplace because everybody is gonna
like just just divulge just jump all over you they
just want your attention for a second right just
to clarify the first time you pitched Netflix
were you pitching them an idea or an actual film
a good great question so the film wasn't made so
I guess it's an idea but the film there was a
script there was the production was ready to go
all the actors were in place I knew where I
was shooting it was just like pre-production
I pitched them at that phase so the movie
I'd already financed the movie by the way
I didn't need them to finance the movie the movie
was already financed ready to go ready to be shot
but I felt like had I if I were to do it again
I would pitch them even earlier this time but
but I pitched them at that point and by the way
I didn't just pitch Netflix I pitched everybody
this wasn't exclusive Netflix Netflix was one of
the companies I pitched I pitched every studio
Disney was where I was hoping to put that movie
full out Disney was the target for it it was
girl-centric it was female empowerment
12-year-olds it's the Disney audience
frankly I was shocked that Disney didn't buy
it Disney bought it for the Disney channel for
the rest of the world but not the united states I
was shocked I expected the sale to come from them
so I'm not disappointed that it came from Netflix
as a great customer and ultimately worked out
fantastic they had a huge huge audience but it
was the Disney audience that I was like when I
pitched my investors and they said where are
you like what's your niche audience who's your
niche target I said it's Disney we're setting up
the movie it's a Disney s style movie it attacks
their audience this is who we're going for so
and I had several meetings with them because I
knew the people there and they just said no and
then luckily Netflix said yes but I also pitched
pretty well every studio I had I knew a lot of
people like sony warner fox I knew people at all
these places through my distribution days so I was
able to get meetings so that's how it happened but
it happened just before I made the movie so there
was lots to pitch on and I had made a promo reel I
obviously I couldn't shoot make a trailer because
I hadn't shot anything yet but I cut a promo
reel almost like a little sort of three minute
documentary about who the I'm making the movie
about where I'm shooting it little narration that
type of thing just to make it a little bit more
visually appealing and it was a good promo reel
did they say why you wouldn't they didn't want
to take on u.s territory Netflix Disney I don't
they didn't like the movie they don't tell you
why they don't tell you why okay and even if they
do tell you why it's just make you feel good it's
what are they going to say to me it's not a good
movie or it doesn't what what they actually they
did say what they said they said it doesn't suit
our audience and I said okay this is confusing to
me number one is Disney channel rest of world took
the movie and it suits their audience but Disney
channel usa said it doesn't suit our audience
and then I said that to them and they said it's
a different audience and I said you're kidding
me but who am I gonna say what am I gonna argue I
just take everything to mean we don't like it
thanks a lot nice try no matter what they say I
just that's what I hear they could say anything
and I hear sorry nice try come back tomorrow
yeah I just wasn't sure how much they told you
because that's very fascinating that they the
rest of the world liked it but the u.s but I don't
believe it you don't believe it I don't believe I
know first of all I know darn well that that movie
plays to their audience they just didn't have room
for it or whatever that's what they told me it was
whatever they needed to tell me to be polite and
get me out the door that movie plays to their
audience we all know it they know it I know it
it's the world is not different that way 12
year old girls are 12 year old girls everywhere
how do you articulate distribution and sales
forecasts to investors well articulate them I
show them charts and basically I show them what
I believe the revenue generation is going to
look like over what period of time which is the
cash flow analysis and then I put it into a nice
concise chart so that they can see it in
sort of a one page that's how I articulate
it now how do I create it I do my own sales
forecast because I have enough distribution
experience to sort of know what to expect
what the levels are what people are paying
it changes all the time obviously because as the
market develops and as new customers come in or
different technology whatever so you
have to constantly keep revisiting that
but you generally do a revenue forecast
based on either comparable movies that have
gone in the past not too far in the past that you
can compare to based on your own experience based
on what you believe you're going to get from a
certain marketplace and you do them at I do them
at five different levels like low semi low medium
medium high high so I do five levels some people
do 10 levels some people do three levels you
can't do you could do one level but it's so I show
what sort of the average that we can expect
is what the home run is what the disaster is
and but a lot of people pay for that so there's
companies that that you can buy revenue forecasts
from that do it for as a service and you pay a
lot of money actually I've seen lots of those
forecasts I don't think they're so credible but
you need something you got to show something to
investors to say that you've done your homework
and this is what a credible company that has
compared it to sort of like movies has shown
the reason I don't think they're so credible is
several reasons one is they're using movies that
have played like 10 years ago they can't they're
talking home video numbers home video doesn't
even exist anymore so they're comparing completely
different technologies and release patterns two
is they're usually using movies that are bigger
at budgets than what an indie film would be so
like they're comparing my movie to home alone
hello they're not even in the same league
they're different businesses so but it's
family audience and this and that type of thing
so I just I'm so so financially response like
not respond I'm responsible but but I'm i'm I'm
so critical financially I gotta make sure that
it makes sense and sometimes the the comps as they
call the comparables are not as credible as when
you talk to say a sales rep who is in the market
right now who deals with today's audience and
today's platforms and you sit them down and say
what do you think and it doesn't matter what 10
movies did 10 years ago what matters is what they
think because they're out there interacting with
customers all the time and selling movies to them
now I also have relationships with some agents
and distributors around the world so I'm able
to call them up and say okay what do you think
and nobody gives definitive answers they give well
it could be this it could be that it could be at
least you get a ballpark and it is a ballpark but
you say to your your investors here's the ballpark
here's the range it could be a big range and
here's what you think the target's going to be
and it's like no different than any other
business opening a restaurant what do you
think your customer base is going to be
and how many meals you're going to sell
building a condominium complex what's the revenue
going to be it's just like that maybe a little
less predictable than that because it's a movie
do you talk to your students at ucsd about that
do they want to know how can I create this even if
it's just for play and excel yeah they do but it's
so I'd need a whole course on that actually it's
so extensive first of all you have to understand
finances a little bit too and I do get into I said
I mentioned cash flow you see so there's how much
revenue you're going to generate but what the
time frame it's going to take to generate it
and that speaks to sort of return on investment
or internal rate of return so for instance if you
invested say a thousand dollars in in today and
next year I gave you back two thousand dollars
you would have gotten 100 return on your or 200
roi like double your money right but over a year
but if if I returned it to you two years later it
would have been over two years so it's a sort of
a different financial analysis for an investor
because they're looking at their annual rate of
return so the longer it takes to return the money
the lower their return on investment has been or
their internal rate of return as we call it this
is beyond what film students want to learn film
students don't sign up to learn this is accounting
stuff this is stuff you learn in business school
this finance right so I don't get I talk about it
but I don't get into too much depth but ironically
we just finished that unit on distribution
and part of the assignment they have to do
an assignment part of the assignment is doing
a very very high level cursory revenue forecast
and everybody said how would we know how to do
that and I said just guess and they said what's
the point I said you'll understand the point
in five years from now just guess okay and the
point of that exercise if my students watch this
video is that they have to go through the motions
to look at the different sort of revenue streams
vod television international so so now they're
considering what revenue streams there are and
they're just putting numbers in it doesn't matter
what the numbers are it's the format of what they
have to think about the numbers don't matter today
because they're going to change tomorrow
and in 10 years or five years when they go
to do their films there'll be a whole different
marketplace with maybe some different categories
it's just the concept of going through the motions
to understand how to set it up that's what matters
and once they turned in those assignments and
you talked about it as a group I'm assuming
maybe you did maybe you didn't what was their
impression of the revenue forecast right so
they had to create and even they're just plugging
in these numbers and they're just maybe guessing
the revenue forecast is a tiny tiny component the
major component of the assignment was marketing
was how to create awareness it was well it was
basically deciding who your audience so each
everybody picked a film to use some people pick
someone my film some people they got to they had
to choose a feature film this is what they do then
they have to tell me who their audience is and why
then they have to tell me how they're going to
create awareness with that audience so which is
a whole marketing campaign like what they're going
to do with social media they're going to do paid
advertising how much they want to spend and why
they can justify that spend then they're going to
tell me what platforms how they're going to make
it accessible to the audience are they going to
do a theatrical release are they going to do video
on demand are they going to try to do subscription
if so what do they expect is their return so they
have to do all the research on all the platforms
and what to expect will they do television
afterwards will they do date releases this kind of
stuff that's the core of it now how much they're
going to make is literally a separate course they
I do that I do two things sort of as add-ons which
are worth fewer points everything is point-based
sort of how much what the revenue would be and
the other thing is do a distribution agreement
so I give them a template for a full distribution
agreement so they can read it and see it and
then I give them a distribution memo and again
they say well how would we know this and I say
you won't just make it up because I don't care
what they say as the like the term of the deal
I care that they know here's the the items
that go into a distribution agreement you
have to know the territory the term the language
is it exclusive what the payouts gonna be what it
I just care that they look at the categories
it doesn't matter what the numbers are
it's funny to read the numbers because they're
all over the place but it doesn't matter it's the
thought process that goes into understanding
what goes into one of these documents
have you ever pitched a completed film
to Netflix oh yeah yeah definitely
well the first one was completed I pitched
it before but then I had to pitch it after
to get it sold the second one was a completed film
kiss and cry that that was pitched after the fact
I pitched do you want me to go through that one
he's already is yeah I pitched another one that
they said no to which I think is my best film
ever but they didn't think so and they said no
and they didn't tell you why didn't no wasn't a
fit for the audience even if they did honestly
I honestly don't even hear why like because I
feel like it's just being polite whatever it is
like if you say it's not a fit for your audience
then their audience is so big everything's a fit
for their audience they they own the entire world
audience so if they say it's not an entertaining
movie then truthfully I guess my ego is too big to
believe that because I've done so many screenings
with it I know it's entertaining to audiences
I've been in so many festivals with the
movie and I've watched real audiences not
friendly audiences people who know me like
complete strangers watch and critique the movie so
I know it's an entertaining movie so when somebody
says it's not an entertaining movie then I say I
respectfully disagree but you get to say it
because I because you own the audience and I don't
but that's okay that's their prerogative it's
their business when we played that one little
game before which I really liked where you
said what's your movie and now I need you
to fill a hundred seats from people that are
not friends and families co-workers whatever
do you ever run out by your students and do it
and do they yeah yeah that's right that's right
in my class oh okay okay that's like lesson two in
my class oh I love it I like that game I actually
should become a board game well no it's because it
really gets you to think critically and it makes
the stakes a little higher to really really dig
in and say okay who would I put into those seats
and what do they say like what are some of the
ideas that these students have come well it
depends on the movie like I don't want to get into
too many details because it's a I don't want to
it's not fair to my students whatever like like
one of the groups did pulp fiction okay so they
went into a lot of detail of who that movie goal
would be now there's probably tons of research
on the internet that they probably could have
borrowed from I don't know but they thought about
what age group what demographic where what that
type of movie would attract that type of thing
so and they gave me reasons of why they thought
that was the people and it doesn't matter again
whether it's right or wrong because there aren't
no writer there aren't right and wrong answers
it's about the reasons why you do the critical
thinking you do so they say they could say that's
for 12 year old girls and as long as they tell me
why they think that and it's rational then they'll
get a good mark now I totally disagree that movie
is obviously not for 12 year old girls because
there's so much violence and swearing and all that
kind of stuff but they wouldn't say that obviously
but they might say males 50 to 70 and I might say
well it's probably males 30 to 50. but tell me why
you think 50 to 70 and they might say because we
think that those males are more mature and have
more time and would like the violence better or
something like that as long as the reasoning is
good it's about the critical thinking because
it's constantly changing as I said right so
I want to create critical thinkers who who can
be creative and just be rational now they'll work
in teams ultimately when they're in the working
world and it's good to have different input and
different ideas and as long as you're not crazy
and delusional and coming as long as you it's
about thinking about it that's what that's what
learning is about is about thinking critically
about something and trying to understand it
best you can it's not about right and wrong
necessarily in this this isn't math there's not a
right answer and a wrong answer this is about how
you come to it was there a waiting period after
you pitched Netflix the first time yeah you mean
until until I got an answer I had the six weeks
or so something like that they had to circulate
the movie internally a bit and think about it a
bit that I can't remember exactly but it wasn't
it wasn't that long like it wasn't more than that
maybe maybe four weeks something like that it was
relatively soon god you're sitting on pins and
needles the whole time you're so anxious but they
do fairs for they have million things to look at
and they they have to get opinions of few people
when Netflix said yes to you what did that yes
mean it meant that I just became a real filmmaker
now it meant like it's surreal at first to
be honest with you it's like holy smokes
but first of all you gotta understand I am
so skeptical about everything because I've
been in business by myself for so long
that I've seen so many deals fall apart
so the truth is and I hate to say
it the truth is and I do this with
everything so people if anybody who's ever
worked for me knows what I'm about to say
it's like the deal's not a deal until the money is
the check has been cashed and cleared in the bank
so even though you have a deal in writing even
though it's all signed sealed delivered you've
delivered the movie when the money comes and it
clears then it's a deal and everybody says like
why can't you just celebrate they said yes you
have a contract here it is they're taking delivery
I said yeah but I've seen lots of deals there
where they falls apart at the end the very end
even though it's what are you going to do you're
going to sue Netflix you're a little like lowly
filmmaker and you're going to take them and you'll
probably settle or something like that if the deal
were to fall through but I kind of wait until the
very end so as much as I was thrilled and happy
it wasn't done until it was paid for do
you think that's a good model to go by do
you think too many people are trusting and
get their hopes up and so that's when you
said you'd been through so much and so much
rejection yeah it seasoned you in a way that
you you're you're more opt to close any gaps that
yeah it's not a good way to be it's good to be
able to really celebrate and everything like that
but but the word you use is right it's seasoned
that comes with experience generally when you've
done being in it enough time that's any business
not just the film business but when you've done
enough times and you've seen sort of what the
scenarios are and how it plays out I just don't
want to set myself up for disappointment and I
underst especially when it's new territory
like it wouldn't happen now with Netflix now
I've got enough experience and I know who
they are and they're big enough company and
everything like that but back then it was the
first deal I didn't know what to expect and I'd
seen a deal go sour a really good deal that I
had done before a few years earlier went sour
at the 11th hour like it was a done deal and it
went sour and I was in a position to sue but I
pursuing's not a good route to take because it's
costly and you don't want to ruin a relationship
so so I guess I'm a little jaded no I'm a
lot jaded but for good reason I'm I am have
a lot of experience I'm super seasoned and
you get jaded when you're seasoned but I do
still allow myself to celebrate when the time
comes but I choose when the time is how many
guaranteed ways are there for a filmmaker to get
their film to Netflix guaranteed ways that's a
kind of a loaded question almost like it's like
it's like leading a witness there's no guarantees
you're talking Netflix the only guarantee is
there's two guarantees one is you're making the
movie for Netflix because they hired you it's
a Netflix original and they hired you to make
the movie that's guaranteed because they own the
movie and they hired you or two is they pre-buy
the movie from you based on an idea or a license
which highly highly highly is unlikely those are
the two guarantees otherwise you do it you hope
for the best but both of those first scenarios are
generally Netflix original movies where it's not
really your movie you're just making it for them
what are some of the non-guaranteed ways to get on
Netflix that just shot in the dark well the first
non-guaranteed way is make a movie make it really
really good create a lot of awareness for it not
necessarily give it away on youtube for free but
do something that gets a lot of maybe social media
activity something that you do special or maybe
release or something like that that's probably
the best non-guaranteed way because it will put
you in a league where you'll be able to get their
attention because now two things have happened
one is you've made a good movie it's finished
so they don't you're not pitching them on an
idea you're pitching them on a finished film
and two is you've also gotten an audience which
they want audience their business is not about
content their business is audience they're in the
business of signing subscribers remember that the
way they subsidize signed subscribers is to create
good content now they're also in the content
business now so someday the value of their content
library is going to be worth a ton of money it
probably already is right now but the major asset
is subscribers and they create good content to get
subscribers so if you can show to them that you
already have like a ton of interest and maybe
some of those people will become subscribers if
they put their movie your movie on their service
that's a gigantic plus for them like if
you're dealing with say a niche audience right
and they don't maybe have that niche audience or
think that they could sign another 20 30 40 50 000
subscribers based on that movie they're gonna be
all over that so that's the best non-guaranteed
way to do it but it's you're making a movie it's
super risky and they also might say no and they
may never see the movie like how do you get it to
them right you gotta have an agent or a manager or
somebody or the best way as I said last time is to
go through an existing distributor who already has
a relationship with them but the best way to get
that distributor is to have that audience to have
that awareness to have that notoriety already it's
not just it's not this is where the narrative is
different it's not good enough anymore to say hey
I have a great movie it's not good enough even to
have laurels from low end film festivals if you
have the audience choice award from toronto or
can yeah you're good but who gets that one movie
a year and it's probably so chances are you're not
going to have that what's good enough is you've
done some marketing and created a lot of awareness
and all of a sudden the distributor slash who's
going to talk to Netflix can say look how much
interest we already have we're not only bringing
a movie we're bringing an audience with it
seems like a lot of authors are doing that as
well so it's very similar they don't get signed
sometimes by these big publishing houses until
they've proven that they have a big social media
following right I could be wrong about that but
but the good news is for here's the good news for
indie filmmakers if we're going to take one piece
of good news is the because of the digital world
you can actually do that now you can actually
reach out to the audience yourself now it's a
super crowded marketplace because they're
inundated with all kinds of stuff but 10 20
years ago you could not connect with the world
with individuals around the world now you can
like I say it's just hard to get through all
the clutter but at least the it exists the
technology exists to do it so if you got a
message and how to work it and manage it and
maybe create this niche area where you can get
it out there at least it's available to do it
whereas before you had to do generic television
advertising or or print advertising whatever and
spend a ton of money and not even know
if you're connecting with your audience
is that something that your students are concerned
with how do they kind of rise above the noise
because there's so much we're inundated with
every day yeah I don't think young people are as
concerned about that because they're part of the
noise they are the noise right I see it as noise
because I'm used to other stuff but but there
they are the noise right so they're well way more
connected than I am way more up to speed on all
the platforms it's constantly changing obviously
I'm not hip I'll tell you the funniest thing
the the one compliment my oldest son paid to me
so the back-ended compliment was dad the only
thing cool about you is that you actually know
that you're not cool I took it as a compliment
okay no that was a total compliment it took so
much pressure off me like I didn't want to have
to chase around and try to pretend that I knew all
these platforms and that I was on instagram and
doing this and all that kind of stuff I don't want
to do tick-tock videos I just don't want to do
that stuff I recognize that it is super important
and that there's a gigantic world out there and
it's very big for marketing I recognize it totally
but at my age and who I am I'm not I'm not going
to do that I'm going to hire people or can I'm
going to circle myself with people who who are
good at it who want to do it who enjoy it more
than I do so I'm not saying it's not important
because it totally is I'm just saying I know
who I am and I don't want to try to be some
cool instagram person or I don't want to be a
youtube influencer I guess maybe through these
videos I'm a little bit but yeah I think you
all no no but what I'm saying is like I don't have
to do these silly weekly videos that are going to
do crazy stuff to make me I don't even want to
do weekly webcasts or podcasts I it's just I'm
not interested so that's what he meant at
least who you are and you're not interested
in that now having said that the young people
are super interested in all that kind of stuff
and it's great because the tools and listen
there's a lot of people who might be in my
class or who are in that generation who are going
to change the world right they're going to come
up with new technologies are they're going to work
in companies that apply these technologies and do
special things that that are going to change the
way people think and new habits and new ways look
what's gone on in the last year with the whole
black lives matter and the whole these are social
movements that change the way people think and
the whole world and so that's great that these are
that's the generation that's gonna embrace
that and take and take charge and hopefully
we'll do do good with it that's great that
you have so many sort of ears and eyes that
are able to tell you different things whether
it's students or your sons and you can kind of
see them in action with whatever on whatever
platform yeah because some people don't and
there's so many things that are changing and
evolving oh this platform's not not no one's
using this now so it's funny for my students
so when we were doing the marketing part and I
was talking about social media I literally said
to them at the beginning of that lecture I said
what I'm about to tell you is what I know but I'm
pretty darn certain hopefully that I'm right that
way more than I do so I'm just going to go through
the motions and in your papers I'm going to learn
more from you from in this section then you're
going to learn from me because I know that you
are active on these platforms and I'm not now
we talked about buying facebook ads and stuff
like that which is I don't do it I hire people
to do that so I understand how it all works and
how to target and do that kind of thing and they
don't didn't know about some of that stuff but
they're going to be way better at it than I am and
it's way more savvy because that's who they are
each deal that you've received on Netflix has it
improved each time it's three films yes it has
that might be a combination of a couple things one
is I got lucky it could be that I just got lucky
that they were paying more each time two is maybe
the films are better but I don't think they're
necessarily better in terms of the production
quality but I think maybe it's because they see
that my films are getting an audience and they're
maybe worth a bit more so they being fair really
fair because they control that side you can have
a little bit of a discussion but for the most part
they say here's where you're going to fit in and
if you say no they got 50 other films waiting in
line to fit in so there's a little bit of room
wiggle room but not a heck of a lot but at least
if they say you're this is what the film is worth
and they recognize that the value is there because
they have an audience and they know it because
they had an audience for the previous one so
so it's similar audiences so that's
maybe why they've been fair like that
have you made any pitches to Netflix during
the pandemic yeah yeah of course I have
the pandemic does I can't shoot anything but
I did pitch them on the movie I wanna shoot
and they're interested but but I told them I'm not
shooting during the pandemic so maybe that's my
bad but I think everybody understands that right
but it was another scenario where it looks good
sounds good we like division we like the style
of movies you make and everything like that but
you're going to need to make it
and make sure you make it well
it's still good do I have a tracker with
them yeah do I have relationships yeah
it's still a new adventure every time
though because they're I'm a little tiny
speck of dust in in their universe and I know it
maybe I shouldn't belittle myself that much but
so I don't take for granted I you got to
deliver and it's got to be good and it's got to
resonate and by the way I still plan on doing all
that audience awareness stuff that I talked about
even more so now now that I'm really aware of
it and real niche and lots and lots of marketing
before it goes to them if they're going to take
it so that I can bring audience to them I want to
be able to say the major pitches to them is like
yeah here's the story and it's a good movie and
it's going to resonate but the major pitches look
at the audience that I think I'm going to be able
to bring to you because of all the marketing I've
done what constitutes niche in the eyes of a of
a platform like Netflix or Hulu or Disney it's
specific like I tend to make family movies and
primarily sports dramas so this one's also a
sports drama based on a true person true like a
true life story so niche would be sort of what the
sport is who this the person is that we're talking
about if there's some sort of like community
around that person that would be interesting
to use a very very big example obviously this
is way bigger than what I'm talking about but
so Netflix recently released the tiger woods
two-part series and it wasn't it was some
filmmaker made it about tiger woods and it was
really really well done it's a matter of I can't
believe how well done it was based on the fact
that he didn't he wasn't part of it they like
it wasn't an authorized biopic they did it based
on footage they got anyways I love golf and so so
look at the niches there first of all you've got
the celebrity of tiger woods in the sports world
you've got the whole golf world because
pretty well anybody who's a golfer is
going to watch that so there's you deal with
the pga the professional golf association and
there's lots of associations like I remember the
southern california golf association everybody
heard about it through that so we all got it
very niche target marketing to the golf world
obviously to the overall sports world and then
the general stuff is to the celebrity world
because he's a major celebrity in his own right
even though he's an athlete but he's probably
more well known in the world than any actor is
or way up there with them so but they say that's
an extreme example because you're talking like
probably the most well-known athlete in the world
but the niche is the golf thing right and so even
if it wasn't tiger if it was some unknown golfer
he still could have gone into the golf world
because generally like I guarantee I know a lot
more golfers than on the pga tour I think so so if
they had used somebody who wasn't the notoriety of
tiger but somebody who was I was interested in
as a golfer they could target me and that alone
would be and then it's also demographics
generally a lot of people who call for
more so male than female but it goes both ways
but they they there's ways to target that sure
and that's a good demographic because that that's
someone that's going to have disposable income
to spend on things even if you're not putting it
on a platform where it's just whatever fifteen
dollars a month and that might be a good place to
start getting someone yeah I would imagine look
at Netflix has such a big audience that I always
assume everybody's got Netflix but they don't but
I always assume everybody does but I would imagine
that there's there were a lot of golfers who maybe
don't have a Netflix subscription that maybe did
sign up for a Netflix subscription just to watch
that special and it was well it was really well
done so they probably got their money's worth now
will they stay subscribers I don't know that's
up to Netflix to start to profile them and feed
them other golf stuff or whatever stuff Netflix
is good at that right suggested yeah films yeah
what's different about the pitching process
with Netflix now versus prior years 2015 2014
like I said before it's bigger company so they
generally they don't take pictures that's a
different I've done business with Netflix for
three films but I'm not going to call myself a
Netflix expert there are people who do way more
business than I do especially different types
of business like internally I haven't done any
Netflix originals I've talked to them about it
there's a different department and different
style and all that kind of stuff so I just
sort of know what I know as an outsider and again
I'm not I guess I'm much further ahead than any
indie filmmaker who hasn't done any business with
them but like I feel like I'm not that qualified
to talk about it but I guess more so than others
but the pitching what makes it different it's just
back then they took pitches they just don't take
them they don't have the time or the interest
unless it's done through the right channels which
is agents or distributors so it's you're basically
locked out now how are your pitches different
now knowing that they're a bigger company they
have less time they have so many people trying
to get into that front door yeah my pitches to
everybody not just Netflix anybody who I'm dealing
with are shorter and more concise and right to the
point because of lack of time and they hear so
much so I get right down to it one it's almost
a log line like here's the movie here's what
it's about and here's the audience and here's
how we're going to go after that audience and
here's what I'm going to bring to the table as
a result here's the marketing I'm going to do and
it's like I say I try to keep it to five minutes
and then the rest is hopefully
questions but that's all you really need
you can get to I could do it in 20 probably 30
seconds but I spread it out just a little bit so
I'm not talking too fast but yeah back then I was
pitching as I said in the last video I would do
20 to 30 minutes for a pitch tell them about the
story tell them about this the actors how we're
going to shoot and they don't care nobody cares
about that stuff just make a darn good movie
tell us who the audience is and deliver so if
I was at Netflix you've just just pitched me
what are my questions going to be to you or am
I just sending you out the door thank you very
much we'll look it over no but remember I'm
not going to get a pitch for something that
I'm unless it's a Netflix original and in that
case I'm sort of just telling them the idea
and that's more about the script because
they're just basically going to buy the
script and maybe hire me to make the film
or maybe just take the script and make it
internally with one of their crews so potentially
I could be hired on maybe to direct or something
and then we would talk it's all artistic
it's not about audience anymore because
they're gonna own the film they'll control that
they'll bring all that to the table so the other
flip side is pitching a finish film you've already
finished the film so you don't have to talk about
the story or this or that so back then I would do
that now I don't talk about any of that because
here's the film like just watch the film I don't
have to tell you what like that's why I say it's
one sentence about the log line but but here's the
film you either want it or you don't want it based
on the movie itself so they're hearing the log
line they're taking the materials maybe they'll
they're watching it and then they'll watch
the movie for sure no no unlike distributors
they'll definitely watch the movie no they don't
watch every movie they'll watch the first 10
minutes and if they like it then they'll watch the
next 10 minutes and hopefully they get through the
whole thing right to make sure that it's okay but
the reason that they'd be interested is because
there's an audience attached to it because
there's like I say if I if I had 10 seconds
to pitch Netflix on and that's all you got right
maybe I should suggest this to Netflix give every
indie filmmaker 10 seconds speed pitching
right or 20 seconds or something like that
I wouldn't even tell them the name of the film
all I'd say is I have 2 million viewers on youtube
who've already seen it and want to see it on
Netflix that's the pitch hopefully that's the case
and they'd say oh by the way what's the name of
the film you sure you got the two million prove
to us you got the two million let's see it did
you jigget did you do something that's the pitch
the film matters but the audience matters more can
we reenact the pitch that you did for your last
movie sure to Netflix how did you let's suppose
I'm the person on the other side of the desk great
to see you have a seat can you get him some water
coffee great thank you no that didn't even happen
they have a nice station in the lobby go get
yourself a drink a coffee whatever and no when we
get up to the meeting room let's get right into it
all right so the pitch was very simple it was like
I want to make another the the the olympics are
coming in two years I believe that we did well
with our first movie with full out and I would
like to make another gymnastics movie similar to
that because with the olympics coming we know that
women's gymnastics is a big thing in an olympic
year and you've already developed that audience
with the first movie would you be interested in
having another one and I've already got a story
and I got an idea of who we would do it with
it would be very similar to the first one but a
completely different storyline but it would engage
the exact same audience and I think that it would
be the timing would be good to deliver it then
during that olympic year similar to what we did
with the first one and what was their response
I like it we like it what tell me more and the
more right there in the meeting okay yeah the
answer was yeah that's a good idea okay what
are you thinking I'm i'm thinking we should do
this this storyline again a minute I've got this
gymnast who who did this and I think it'd make
a really good story and instead of doing hip-hop
dancing I want to do break dancing in this one so
similar type of thing with two characters that
meet but let's go into the break world because
it's really cool these days and the music
is really good and I think that'll resonate
okay great idea when when you wanted to
shoot it and blah blah blah I'm going to
shoot it then when would you deliver okay
we would need it by here by this time and
then the number then how much
would you be willing to pay
and then we get into that and that takes a
minute or two now but they also by the way
they're sitting with an ipad and they're
saying oh let's see what did fallout 1 do
yeah okay the numbers look pretty good all right
let's talk about the next one they would actually
give you that number oh no they don't tell you
they they're looking at their ipad they're not
telling you they're saying yeah okay looks
okay we're good we're good to go next I say
can you share the can you turn the ipad around
I want to see the numbers no we don't do that
it would be really good I put some of my heart
and soul into it can't you just throw me a bone
here tease me give me one number sorry we don't
do that we don't do that and they don't do that
that's their proprietary information and
that's the way it works but luckily the
numbers were good on that ipad otherwise the
conversation would have been really short
and so this was less than a 10-minute meeting this
last one the substance was 10 minutes there might
have been five minutes of pleasantries how are
you doing how's the golf game nice office whatever
yeah but yeah yeah it took about 10 minutes but
there was one other piece of business in that
movie because I was wanting to do a renewal on the
first one too it was coming up for renewal and so
we were talking about both the renewal and the
next one I see okay yeah and the numbers were
good so both happened the renewal and the the
new one so that works in your favor obviously
so you go in there with good numbers and then you
pitch them something else it's everything if the
numbers aren't good it's over it's over before
it starts yeah there's nothing to talk about
getting the first one is the tough one because
you don't have any numbers the second one if
your numbers are good it's really easy meeting and
if your numbers are bad it's a very tough meeting
you got to explain why your numbers are going
to be better the next time around if they're
even interested to hear it but the subject matter
is super niche I know that audience really well
I've done tons of marketing to it they know I'm
connected to it they know that I know how to get
to that audience and create viewership there
so because I've already done the marketing and
now even more so we're gonna like and I explained
what we're gonna do in addition to this with the
dance world that we didn't do last time so that's
music to their ears and hopefully it works and
hopefully they get new subscribers as a result
of it I want them to be successful because if
they're successful then hopefully they greenlight
something else I'm going to do and that's just
supporting their efforts how are you sharing your
ideas for marketing the film that you're pitching
so with Netflix or with everybody let's see for
this for this case yeah Netflix oh I'm telling
them straight up I'm saying okay we're going
to start with the gymnastics the usa gymnastics
which is their network of all the gyms across
the united states and the coaches so we're gonna
we're gonna get an endorsement from them I had
a special olympian in there so we're going to
special olympics we're getting their
endorsement meaning they'll put the
message out to all of their athletes
and families of which they have many
we I'm dealing with the dance magazine
and dance world so there's all kinds of
dance tons of dance clubs and studios and
so I'm advertising through them I'm doing
both paid advertising and social media and
then we're doing some a whole bunch of of
web-based stuff with one of our key dancers so the
main breakdancer in the movie is a world-renowned
breakdancer and so she did interactive stuff
that we had all planned pre-planned as part of
the promotion and so they don't know anything
about the breaking world I didn't know much
about it either I learned about it obviously but
so as I explained it to them and they looked up
who this is and what these communities are and
how to get to them and everything like that and
that's probably a good audience for them and
they probably have a lot of that audience already
but it's interesting for for them to hear about
it so these are things that you're explaining
not in a ton of detail just enough to tweak their
interests and make them see that you're going to
do some hard work and really engage try to engage
an audience and that's for everybody's benefit
primarily for the benefit of my movie because I
want audience on it by the way this is before they
say yes right so I'm doing this anyways regardless
of whether they say yes I'm doing because I want
to be successful with my movie so if they
don't say yes maybe I take it to apple tv
and pitch them the same thing or to to Hulu
or something like that which by the way did
so because you're waiting six weeks you're not
sitting there with your thumb up your butt waiting
for an answer you're pitching everybody because
you you hope that somebody comes through and you
hope it's the one you want but it's kind of like
applying for for lack of a better example college
you don't apply to one you apply to one that's
a disaster unless you're pretty darn sure you're
going to get in you apply to 10 or and you hope
that you're just hedging your bets a little bit
so the long line is equally important as how
you'll market to your audience and who your market
who your audience is it sounds like neither is
more important than the other you've got to have
both the log line is just for pitching everybody
on their platform doesn't put just a log line they
put a synopsis you go into Netflix and you see
a three or four sentence synopsis on every film
so the log line is just when you're pitching
it's the yellow it's what the people call the
elevator pitch thing you got three floors in
an elevator and you better get it out quickly
so you just get a log line in there that
sort of captures what the movie's about
and then as soon as you capture their attention
then they might ask you more details and you can
go into a little bit more detail but I find by
the way I find that filmmakers the big mistake
they make in pitching and they do this all
the time when I'm consulting with them is they
talk way too much about the story we all know
story elements we get it we know genres I know
pretty well all of them so just like tell me the
details because I say to them this is the irony
so they're paying me for their time they might
book an hour right and they're paying for that
and they start going into the story and I say no
no no let me stop here for a second I don't want
you wasting your time your paid time telling me
your story I get it I get the audience I get who
you're talking about I don't need the details of
the story I'm sure it's great I'm sure it's unique
let's get into the substance the substantive stuff
which is the marketing and the distribution all
that kind of stuff because don't take 20 minutes
to tell me your story because they would otherwise
because they're so engaged in their story and
it's not about the story it's obviously at the
end of the day when you make the movies about
the story but it's not about the story at that
at that stage that's why I was wondering is how
important it sounds like then the synopsis or log
line whatever it is you're going off to pitch them
is equally important as who's your demographic
who how are you getting to them well think about
it like you're sitting there you're Netflix buyer
right I'm saying to you I'm going after the
dance world in the gymnastics world okay as
long as I have a decent story where there's
characters and character arcs and development
everything like that the question they need to ask
is how many dance routines am I going to have how
many gymnastics routines am I going to have oh
yeah what's the main character and what's their
relationship but how many big production scenes
are going to like kids want to see the gymnastics
and the dance that's what they really want to see
and as long as it's not a disaster the rest of it
it's got to have a story that weaves through and
a compelling storyline and like I say character x
and everything like that but but if you have all
that and you don't have good production like you
don't have any dance sequences or or gymnastics
competitions or something like that it's not going
to be a good movie for that audience so that's
really what if you understand who your audience is
and I understand my audience because I make movies
for them then I'm saying to Netflix this is what
my audience wants to see and they understand
that because they have shared audience and
they understand what audiences like to see fame tv
show fame yeah for sure all of the dance routines
interwoven they had they had trouble cheering they
had cheer on there that sure was a series that
they did about cheerleading so they understand
that market really well but now that's in the
department that acquires that's the licensing side
so that's who I'm pitching to is they're going to
acquire the movie right if you're pitching to
Netflix originals where you're talking story
this pitch might be totally different it might be
way more about story character arc plot points all
this kind of stuff they're going to get more into
the artistic side of it because they're going to
be making the movie with you so they want to see
some of the artistic vision but this is you're
making a movie and you're going to tell them
why it's marketable and you're hopefully going
to make a good movie that they're going to buy
they're not involved at all artistically so it's
sort of a different style altogether not sort of
it is it is you're not talking creatives with them
you're talking about audience that you're going to
resonate with when you deliver this finished film
the film's done they have no say in it
because it's you can't change it it's over
whereas in the other side the Netflix
original it's nothing's happened yet they can
change everything and you would have a broader
audience for this because I'm thinking of like
the tv show dance moms I believe I've never
actually watched it I've just seen trailers
but you have not only the the kids in the in the
thing that are the dancing the dancers sorry but
you also have the the mom so you have a much
wider you have parents and you have their kids
oh yeah and I just told you two components I
went break dancing and gymnastics of course
there's there's lots of ancillary stuff and
everything yeah now I have a whole marketing plan
I just didn't want to spend too much time on this
interview talking about it but we could go into a
lot more detail about like all the components of
what we did I did a whole bunch of promotions too
like for example I'll just give you one we shot
that particular movie we shot in oklahoma city
at the university of oklahoma with the oklahoma
sooners it's about one of their gymnasts and
it's shot on location there so I did a huge
promotion in oklahoma city with pizza hut
and I created a lot of awareness by doing a pizza
top box topper that goes out to I don't know 50
000 pizzas they sell in whatever period it was
so that the local audience because the girl's
wearing a oklahoma sooners outfit that's the key
art so everybody in oklahoma city knows who the
sooners are you might not know but everybody
there does from seeing your movie yeah okay so
so that's local stuff yeah we also did lots of
television publicity spots there we got a lot of
ads and not ads but we got a lot of spots on local
editorial public they were all interested that a
movie was being shot on location about a true
story about one of their gymnasts so we got lots
and lots of that which I used in that market more
so I'm not going to use that nationally because
it doesn't resonate but locally it resonates
really well so but the Netflix of the world
understand all that stuff because their business
is engaging audiences so they get something like
some kansas city reporter doing a story of brennan
dowell which is what happened is great in kansas
city and that's good and what does that mean to
Netflix it's one tiny component of their entire
base but it's better than nothing and maybe they
can sign up ten a thousand more subscribers there
in that marketplace based on that maybe this is
micromanaging running a business so and building
your audience no those are great details and
I love that and I love that you would think of
pizza hut maybe that's something that but families
are going to be ordering pizza and who's going
to want to see the pizza hut thing first of all
there's I should have brought it there's a whole
flyer that we printed with a with a a discount on
watching the movie you get a so the reason pizza
hut was in was so the the win-win was they stuck
this flyer it was like a postcard size thing of
the graphic and I'm saying new movie available
on the following platforms and it's like six
transactional platforms and then the flip side
is special promotion from pizza hut 50 off in
this market with this pizza and here's the code
and you stick it in and you get it for 30 days
you can watch the movie for half price with the
purchase of this pizza so it's a win-win but hold
on that was just one that's one promotion I do
tons of those and pizza hut was just one of the
there's 10 pizza chains so I pitched like five of
them not just pizza hut I wanted pizza hut but if
pizza had said no maybe it was dominoes you're
pitching everybody but like I say I spend way
more time marketing than I do on making movies
way more time that's the kind of stuff you're
talking about and to kind of go back to what
I was talking about before filmmakers first
of all don't even know about this kind of stuff
secondly what filmmaker wants to do that film like
talking to 10 pizza joints to figure out a local
pizza promotion you don't want to do that you
want to make movies studios have all this built in
they just take for granted all that kind of stuff
independent filmmakers don't even know about this
stuff this is stuff that's totally foreign that
they would never get around to they don't have
enough time to get around to it let alone to do
it even if they knew about it like I'm telling you
like to me this is like a no-brainer I'm talking
about it it's like that's nothing compared I can
tell you some way more niche stuff than that like
that is a pretty big promotion there's stuff
that's even smaller and you're saying wow
that's interesting and I'm thinking that's not
that interesting that's kind of what you do
how are you getting a mom and
daughter in chicago to care about
a gymnast from oklahoma because hopefully
the daughter's taking gymnastics or dance
and hopefully she's connected to a gymnastics
or a dance club where her coach says hey this
new movie came out it's really nice family fair
I think you and your family would enjoy it and
potentially a little bit of social media where
we're targeting maybe facebook ads that target to
that depends how old the daughter is maybe she's
12 that's our core audience for that kind of movie
and maybe they facebook has all these
analytics and everything so that's part of it
but yeah we're we're reaching out a different
the more direct stuff is through the clubs
and we send we send the clubs every club got sent
a postcard kind of similar to what I was talking
about every club to the coach when we did the
first one if it wasn't the pandemic because the
clubs were closed and the first one we sent a
poster to every club and asked them to hang the
poster a sign poster was a nice really nice poster
so that was a nice sort of thing to put in their
lobby so and that creates awareness and then of
course we have a website which they go to and get
details and that type of thing and that's generic
marketing it's specific to that audience but this
is what I'm talking about like there's so much
involved in marketing when you do marketing for
a living that's not that special what I just said
and it's special but not that special but when you
do filmmaking all of a sudden marketing is like
holy smokes I didn't even know about this stuff
like this is this is really good like I didn't
even know you could do that kind of stuff
yeah there's a creativity in what you're telling
me because there's different things you can plug
in here and it's a challenge it doesn't sound
that easy there's creativity in knowing what to do
and then there's execution and actually doing
it which is a lot of work if that stuff doesn't
come overnight you got to work it and you got
to negotiate it and contract it and deliver
and print and do all this kind of stuff but when
it works it you can get really good results how
has the pandemic changed the film business great
question very timely the major change is obviously
the theatrical business theater's closing so
that's had a huge impact on how movies are
viewed now especially the big blockbuster
tentpole releases so that's a big one but
that also caused a huge change in in the
whole vod world like the streaming world
so all these studios that were probably
thinking about becoming subscription video
on demand services had it in the works likely
accelerated their plans and now all of a sudden
you've got eight or ten major streaming services
when before you had Netflix really was it and then
an amazon prime and then of course Disney plus
was starting up but Disney plus really jumped
in quickly and then everybody followed so I think
that the studios realized they needed another
avenue to to exhibit their movies because they
couldn't depend on the theaters obviously and
that accelerated that so much and I'm not sure
if it's good or bad I think for indie films
it's actually not good which I'll talk about
later but probably for overall viewership for
for consumers now there's such a vast choice of
quality programming that's available at really
affordable prices so I guess that's good now me
personally I love going to the movies like I like
a night out at the movie theater I love watching a
big movie on in a big format on a huge screen with
a great sound system in a very confined like dark
room like that so I for one will be back at the
movies the minute they start up because I it's a
night out for my wife and I love watching a movie
that way hopefully a lot of people are thinking
like me and can't wait to get back to the movies
but a lot of people went out and bought really
big flat screen tvs and good sound systems and
I did too and I enjoy that it's been a great way
to watch content in the comfort of your own home
but I believe that the theatrical business will
be back and it will be healthy and robust and
just because human beings need to go out and need
to socialize and that's a night out do you think
things will be totally the same as they were let's
say 2019 right right toward december of 2019 once
things start to open up I know we're on the eve
of it as of this interview but do you think things
will be returned to that exact level or there
will be changes yeah it's all driven obviously
by the the major studios because they have
the big programming that people want to see so
I don't know just because there's going to be
a decision made corporately in in each of their
boardrooms and they're going to say hey let's do
the math on this if we open theatrically for six
to eight weeks pre vod what will the numbers look
like if we go day and date what will the numbers
look like it's all about numbers right they're in
business to make money and they got to decide what
is the best way to to cater to their audience so
that they can make the revenue they want to make
so I really don't know I know the theaters
I don't know for sure but what I've read is
the theaters obviously are going to want
an exclusive window pre the vod release
but maybe the studios have learned something
new that may carry on and frankly as a consumer
that's not going to matter to me I don't really
care whether there's a day-and-date vod release
with the theatrical release I'll still go to the
movie theater to see the movie because I want to
see it that way and I will pay my 15 and buy
my popcorn everything because I want to go out
I want to I want to watch those big movies that
way so even if they're offered at the same time
on vod I'm still not going I'd rather consume
it that way now if they're not and that's a way
to get subscribers by offering them day and date
that's a corporate decision and I'll understand
but I don't know movie theaters so if I did I
wouldn't understand how has the pandemic changed
your company and you as a filmmaker that's a great
question well my company did not make a movie in
2020 we were supposed to I have a great other new
sports drama that I was hoping to shoot and I've
already kind of almost set up pre-distribution
for it so I was really excited about it
and but the pandemic slowed that down because the
protocols for shooting were very very restrictive
and plus personally I don't really want to do that
I don't I didn't want to put my own health at risk
I didn't want to put the crew or the cast or
anybody at risk so I didn't feel it was worth it
to to have to shoot during the pandemic and it's
still in it's still sort of waiting I'm hoping
maybe we could shoot this fall but we have to see
how that all plays out but I'm respectful of the
fact that hey it's a pandemic crazy thing crazy
year crazy almost year and a half now by the time
this is over but it happens and we'll get through
it and we'll see what looks like on the other end
so I'm anxious to to shoot a game but I
didn't want to shoot during the pandemic
which meant I had like a year more little more
than a year to do other stuff so that actually
was interesting and at first I was kind
of disappointed but then I said let's
make lemons into lemonade here so I did two
things one is I stepped up my consulting practice
quite a bit so I do a lot more consulting with
indie filmmakers and I'm enjoying that because
everybody is kind of struggling and going through
the same thing and it's nice to chat with people
and give them advice and I think I've connected
with a lot of filmmakers and I feel like they've
learned a lot and I've hopefully helped them
through stuff and I'm sure some of them will
be watching this interview and hopefully make
nice comments but also I started teaching too
so I live in san diego I teach at san diego state
university and I teach in the film production
department but I teach the business aspects of
indie filmmaking so it's primarily distribution
and finance which are the boring parts of the
film business the students want to learn about
camera and lighting acting directing editing all
that kind of stuff film making right production
so they have to take my course to graduate if
you're if you're a film major and they learn about
finance and distribution primarily a little bit
about budgeting and scheduling and so it's been
interesting because at first the students are
a little leery of it because they don't realize
what that entails but I've really gotten great
feedback on that from all the students who are
taking my course and they're primarily upper
level students because they didn't really
understand distribution at all they've heard the
word but they had no clue what it is I talk a lot
about marketing and how to kind of make sure
that you've got your plans in place before you
start shooting so that maybe you'll do things
differently during your shoot if you need to
and the whole financing piece everybody's really
curious about how that is all gets put together
there's legal terms technical terms
lots of business terms which yeah
people who are artists and filmmakers don't
really love that but totally appreciate it
once they understand how it all fits together to
become the film business and so in my course I
call it the business of film the students call it
the film business I always say you should put the
business part first not the film part but they're
both equal you need to have the art obviously the
artistic side but they're taking a dozen courses
on that side and one course in business and maybe
that will expand into more I believe in order to
be a successful filmmaker as I've said many times
in your interviews and to other people it's
really helpful to know what really goes on on
the business side primarily the distribution side
you don't have to do it all and I tell people you
don't have to become an expert in it but it's good
to understand it to at least be aware what goes on
what other people do so that you you can be part
of the conversation and the narrative and just be
a little bit more up to speed so that when you do
cross those bridges at least what the bridge is
and what do you start out with once you get
through all of sort of the the housekeeping
of the of the course and the timeline and what
materials they need what do you start with so
it's interesting so I teach in my course which
is the business aspects of filmmaking I teach
three units I teach distribution production and
finance and I actually teach them in that order
so inevitably the first question I get asked is
why are you teaching distribution before you teach
production like shouldn't you be teaching all
the legals and business aspects of making a movie
which is production before you teach selling
a movie or how about you shouldn't you teach
financing a movie before you teach selling
or making a movie but I chose those that that
order on purpose because I said in order to be a
successful filmmaker because I teach about sort of
commercially viable filmmaking obviously you have
to be a good artist you have to make a good film
you can't sell a bad film so I take for granted
I say I assume you're going to make a good film
that's what the other teachers are teaching at you
how to make a great film so I'll check that box
but before you make that great
film you really need to understand
three major things who your audience is who you're
making it for how you're going to create awareness
with that audience and will your audience pay
to consume it if you want to make money with
your movies and that's all distribution so it's
really important to understand those components
before you make your film because one is you might
make a different film two is you might not make
the film you're making if you really want to look
at the business component so that like at the end
you don't struggle and say oh if I only would
have known or if I had a thought of that first
that's why I teach distribution first because
distribution really is enlightening to understand
sort of the film that you're crafting so that
you make the right film so you could sell it
afterwards and even while you're making it
you have to understand distribution so that
maybe you have you're making components that help
you market the film or maybe even doing social
media from set or that type of thing you're
marketing marketing marketing preparing to
sell your film before you make it have you been
surprised by any of the questions or actually
just pleasantly sort of enlightened by how
advanced some of these individuals are when it
comes to distribution yeah well no all I'm going
to say 99 I'd say probably 100 of students who go
to film school go to learn production that's what
film school is teaching you how to make a movie
I think our school san diego state university
recognized that it's really important
to teach distribution of finance because
those are such important components of
being a successful career filmmaker but for the
most part students don't expect to learn about
those kind of things because those are sort of
the business things and film schools about the
artistic things so at first I'm not surprised
they're surprised the students are surprised
when they take the course they have to take my
course to graduate if you're a film major so
it's a prereq there's two prerequisites and it's a
mandatory course so I'm the course they don't want
to take because it's all the boring stuff it's
legal business stuff that type of thing but once
they do take it and they start understanding about
how distribution works and what the different
platforms are and how they buy and sell and how
movies get financed and this kind of thing they're
totally intrigued by it they're probably a little
overwhelmed by it as well because there's so much
that they haven't really thought about financing
a movie is in my estimation far more complicated
than making the movie or editing it like I say
everything's important I'm not belittling any
everything anything but to understand how
the whole system works from start to finish
as a business is fascinating for them and they're
learning a lot they're learning things that they
had no idea they were going to learn about so I'm
really happy with how much they're being exposed
to and learning but they're also there's lots and
lots of questions because once you learn a little
bit you want to kind of learn more and there's
just not enough time to answer it all as a matter
of fact I've had to cut my materials in half
twice because there's just so much to teach and
I take for granted because I know it all that
they can I can go quicker but but I have to go
a little slower because I just throw around terms
like like vod a v o d t v o d s v o d like no big
deal right like that's if you're in the movie
business about that you don't know about that
if you're a film student you don't know what those
platforms are you've heard of Netflix you've heard
of Disney plus you've heard of some of these
things but you don't necessarily know what all
these things are so I have to really take time to
explain all that kind of stuff and it's important
because now they have a very good handle on
potentially where the movies they're going to
make are going to go and of course it's going to
change probably changes all the time but for now.